bonjour moi je pas dit on se connaît
facilement que je vous parle même pas de
ma fille l'un sein de votre fils
monsieur lui a fait un enfant il est
parti qui comprenait le problème seul
problème que je vaux à madame c'est que
je n'ai pas de vie ce n'est pas terre de
chez nous qu'est ce qui vous a dit soir
c'est sa mère qui comme vous le disiez
que vous regretter de l'avoir abandonnée
surtout le demandait de partir la même
erreur je peux monter dans ma voiture
non bagués c'est vrai que j'avais un peu
même sourire en biais pourquoi tu l'a
vite pas boire un petit café
je vais partir j'aime bien ce n'était
pas une bonne idée cette rencontre donc
devenu alors l arrêté tapie lui
volontairement sans nous dire quand même
pas fait exprès d'oublier sa pilule et
bien si figurez-vous c'est vraiment une
fouteuse de merde ça va bien bien
est ce que tu es tombée enceinte
volontairement mais je crois qu est ce
que ça change je voulais vous dire que
vous aviez raison pour claire à une
excuse et aussi pour la gifle
le jld c'est bien c'est une fille mais
c'est comme ça les nourrit sont des
brouillons ces chiffres ni un enfant pas
de mariage beaucoup de femmes si j'ai
bien compris des scories si t'es pas
même beaucoup
gabriel embrassez vous vous voyez les
utile parce qu'on l'a
jamais un jour tu en as envie je
pourrais essayer d'être un père
comment voulez vous occuper d'un bébé je
n'ai même pas commencé faire si tout
petit problème c'est que sa part pas
mais bien piéger un petit dîner chez moi
rue de l'année en plus rien plus nom de
la rue j'aurais dû me méfier pouvoir
mais son petit pyjama
on va donner la petite mamie il faut
leur parler ils adorent ça
sur ce ton